tonight I thought we would go over
another pawn structure so this was a
request that was sent in by some club
members and in a rare moment of
generosity I'm gonna do what three
different people wanted people kept
saying they wanted different things
so I'm gonna do it all tonight we're
gonna go over the French pawn structure
because that was recommended by somebody
somebody else suggested you know why
don't you show your own games so alright
I'm gonna show some of my own games for
I think the first time it's you know
like my 60th lecture I don't think we've
gone over any of my games so embarrass
myself a little bit tonight and then
somebody was like you know make sure you
show a loss so all right fine Mario show
a loss and then my showed up to Ben
Simon's like you're going to show a loss
oh yeah I'll show a loss all right so
we'll embarrass myself a little bit
tonight that's fine but for now we're
going to throw it over to the board
we're going to look at three different
structures so it's kind of the whole
family of French depends on structures
that you might see because what tends to
happen is at some point pawn structures
convert themselves into a different type
of pawn structure so it starts one way
but then when there's some exchanges of
pawns the pawn structure changes so it's
it's kind of important to just get a
good idea of you know what to do in
different pawn structures and this is
Tuesday night not Monday with the
openings class so on Tuesdays we can
tell you the the truth about Tuesday's
so really in chess and I think somebody
said this hopefully you online can tell
me who said this because I I tried to
look it up quickly and I couldn't figure
out who actually said this but it's been
said maybe or else I made it up there
are no openings and chess only pawn
structures so really the pawns are going
to tell you where you want to put all
your pieces they're going to outline the
plans for you in the middle game they're
really going to tell you what it's all
about and then if this was you know a
Saturday technical challenge then I just
tell you it's just as 99% tactics so
there's no openings or strategy or pawn
structures just tack
so depending on the day I'll tell you
whatever whatever you want to hear but
today we're going to look at this pawn
structure that comes generally out of
the French advanced so it can also come
out of sort of a caro-kann if you can
imagine the C pawn somewhere else
and I kind of like this it's a nice
closed structure so when you we start
with the French I think this is a great
one to look at because the pawns have
already sort of outlined where both
people are going to be playing now White
has more space on the Kings side you can
see that as farthest advanced pawn is on
e5 which is on the Kings side and you'll
see that the pawns tend to point towards
the Kings side so this is another good
indication of where you want to play so
you can see that okay so the pawns are
kind of pointing that way you get more
space over there equally black has more
space on the Queen side the farthest
advance pollen is the pawn on d5 and you
can see the pawns sort of aim towards
the Queen's side so that's where both
players should be playing so the big
plan here for white in general is to
play on this side moves like f4 and f5
this is a typical maneuver that we might
see in the middle game and from here I
can either take on e6 or I can play a
move like f6 which might be useful in an
attack so since I get to play on the
King side and black most frequently
castles over here on the Kings side it's
typically white in the structure that
can get a big attack we can imagine the
bishop on d3 we can imagine a queen
coming in we can imagine Knights coming
in this Bishop also might sometimes be
useful so in this type of position it's
actually white that might be thinking of
an attack if black is castled over there
so sometimes as black you don't Castle
right away you just kind of wait in the
center for awhile and maybe you castle
maybe you don't later depending on on
the position because we can also imagine
there is the possibility of Greek gifts
if we have all of our trio of pieces
here so that's something we always want
to keep in the back of our mind and
black for his part we'll try to get some
counter play against the center so you
can imagine a move like c5 and white
will typically bolster the center with
pon and black can get all of his pieces
into the attack on d4 so the knight goes
to c6 the wing goes to b6 this is a very
common occurrence and black tries to get
counter play on the center and on the
Queen side it's also very common at some
point the other break so if you don't
play c5 your other major break in this
position it's going to be F six which
often is a good way to get counter play
and make it slightly more difficult for
white to attack because sometimes it's
hard to attack when stuff is happening
in the center if you can make a lot of
tension in the center it can be you know
quite difficult to attack sometimes
because things can change and if the
center falls apart you better check make
me or I'll just take the center
anyway somebody also asked me to like
why would anybody play this way is black
white just like a tax why would you want
to get attacked well it's it is double
edged so one thing that happens too is
when white moves all of his pawns and he
goes and he tries to checkmate you he is
making lots and lots of weaknesses so he
does have to go try to get you but he
can leave lots of weaknesses behind so
very often in the French the endgame
will actually favor black because white
makes a lot of weaknesses in an attempt
to get after the king and if you break
through in the center or on the Queen
side white could actually end up in
trouble so that's one reason to play
this way as black and okay we'll sort of
see these games these plans in action
I'm going to show the first game so
let's see and we will be going over my
games for some reason and we'll flip the
board all these games were played in
2013 or 2014 because that's about when I
stopped playing chess really because I
started working here so something if you
if you want to get good at chess don't
work at a chess club that's like the
worst thing you can do for your chess
this is a game I played against Club
favourite Preston Smith so the people in
the audience probably know Preston yeah
yeah junior bug yeah he's a guy that
says junior bug cause everyone that he
walks in says I'm the champ the champs
here I'm the greatest a lot of funny
quips from him you know there's only two
great chess players in the world and I'm
both
you know he's out there trash-talking
with with the best of them and what it
was really fun about playing Preston
it's it's always a lot of fun and he's
like 18 he was like 1850 at the time of
this game which i think was his peak
so let's it was the right time to play
him is he will just attack you no matter
what even if it's not called for like
he's just going to attack you he's going
to play for tactics so the games are
always entertaining like it's just a
guarantee it's going to be an exciting
game so this was the show-me classic
from 2013
we'll get the de pon structure on the
board so here we have it was the French
advance and the most common move here is
b6 getting more pressure on d4 but I
played Bishop d7 that's what I like to
play and then usually I'll play f6 and
I'll move my king I'll even castle over
on the Queen side and I'll attack you on
the Kings side so that's what happens
sometimes that's at least how I was
playing the French at that time and here
already a strange move he played Bishop
to e3 and okay I mean so done defends
the pawn and I've actually had
conversations with Bill Thompson who
used to work here
we used to talk about this because he
always liked to play it this way so he
would play this position you always play
here and you would argue for how good it
is but not a particularly good move in
my opinion so probably Queen b6 is the
most appropriate move we're going to go
kind of quickly through the games were
mostly focused here on the pawn
structure but there's some funny stuff
that happened all right so I'm on as
beep on so he protects it and so what
happened in this game - you'll see this
is a very useful piece for him you know
so if I ever Castle this way maybe I'll
get into some trouble but after a pretty
simple maneuver here I forced him to get
rid of his LightSquared Bishop and
already my position is quite good now
it's easy for me to get my pieces out I
can you know get this guy out and I can
castle and double on the C file so I
already have pressure on the Queen side
and he's you know a long ways away from
attacking me I mean I know he will
attacked me at some point because he's
Preston but
all right so I get my pieces out and
then a3 was also a pretty bad move for
him that ultimately will will cost him
the game here so all right so I'm gonna
put my queen on b3 at some point right
he finally played g4 like I was waiting
for that because it's Preston so I
didn't like I knew he's gonna play g4 at
some point and in some position here I
went in so he's going to go attack me
even if there's no attack he's just he's
still gonna do it
and all right I'm just infiltrating into
the light squares now he noticed I've
sort of lined these people up for a
night so he went here and I had seen
this and then here I thought maybe ten
minutes or something and he just blitzes
so I knew he was going to spend less
than five minutes for all of his moves
so this is the only move I thought about
all game like this the only time it
actually calculated and we were both
playing fast and that's that's kind of
how this game went and here I played a
tactical move so this is this year I'll
actually pause and you could pause at
home get a little more time but I guess
all I'll test the audience for the first
time what tactical move did I play and
obviously I understand that this is
coming potentially yeah yeah so it's
tough that's why I had to calculate here
make sure that this move worked but when
I played Queen b3 this is what I
intended it's on this position I'm going
to give it away I took on a3 so
obviously if he just takes back then I
take on c3 and then one second
you know he blitzed out this move which
unfortunately doesn't work for him so I
take this pawn and after he takes back
first to trade the Queen's and then take
the rook and then take this and so now
I'm up upon but I also have three
passers so we'll show the rest of the
game just for fun but okay now I just I
just go and I win so this is what
happened to this pawn structure I win on
the Queen side but he's still going to
attack me somehow you know I didn't I
didn't see that move coming but he's
going to come get me and then okay now
he's going to get checkmated very soon
so he he resigned in this position but
what it really sort of showed in this
position is I got all the counterplay on
the queenside that I wanted and he did
nothing on the kingside I mean he
eventually got stuff going but I was
able to get his like squared Bishop
which was huge and then you know I found
a tactic on the queenside where I had
that's where I should be looking for all
my counterplay and it all just worked
out for me so it's always fun to play
Preston that was a good one
let's look at it for whites point of
view for some reason so this is the
second French pawn structure that we're
going to look at tonight and the way
that this can happen is if white takes
on f6 and black takes back usually with
a knight sometimes with the Queen you
can reach this pawn structure and when
showing somebody this - and just this
outline they're like this is horrible in
the obvious thing that they thought you
know it's just horrible and why would
black ever accept this pawn structure is
the pawn on e6 so it seems like an
obvious target okay you can put rooks
and Queens on the e-file
I can you know I can get bishops and
Knights I can just attack that your
pawned a whole bunch of times so why
would black ever want this and it's true
and especially if white can reach an
endgame where he's got this awesome
night here and black is you know stuck
with this bad bishop behind the pawn
chain then this can turn out really
really good for white so what a black
does obviously have to be kind of
careful and get some active counter play
to offset the backwards pawn and just
focusing still on White's plans I
usually tell all of my my students that
attacking a backwards pond like this is
really a three-fold process so step one
is controlling the square in front of
the pond so you can imagine rook on the
e-file you can imagine a knight maybe a
bishop everybody looking in and
protecting not that far
not that far this square right in front
of the pond and the second step is to
actually blockade the pond so we want a
piece here a night would be really nice
you know Bishop might also be fine or
rooking queen depending on what's left
on the board might also be a very good
piece just to have sitting there and
once it's blockaded then you can start
focusing on the pond itself now it's
time to actually start going after and
targeting the pond and with this method
it makes sure that black never gets to
liberate his position if like ever in
this position gets to play move like 'if
I've and then the bishops can just come
out very comfortably normally a black is
you know at least equal in such a
position maybe even better because if
you can imagine this and maybe can we
get rid of this pawn smile you can
imagine a position like this that might
occur and now black has one extra
central pond so this could actually be
favorable for black if this sort of
thing were to occur so why would black
accept this pawn structure well
typically we're going to get a lot of
active play you can imagine perhaps I
can sacrifice a rook on f3 shatter your
pawns you can imagine this bishop what's
his job in life well sometimes he does
the French maneuver or the Dutch
maneuver based on whichever opening you
play more often you can do the wiggle
and you can go all the way over it's
like h5 where perhaps you're putting a
knight that seems like a decent square
for the bishop and you are looking for
some active play you know also you can
attack the center you know you can get a
pawn structure like this look some what
a pawn fell by the wayside but you can
imagine a pawn structure like this we
can get some pressure against the center
and we'll show a game now where that I
play it against the player in at about
2050 or so I don't know what he was
rated at the time of this game thank you
it was 2,000 already now he's probably
much higher because this was 2014 the
millionaire satellite so whoever won
this got to go to that the millionaire
in Vegas tournament for free so so that
was pretty cool and let's skip the
opening on the board
bird all right so we got the tirage and
at some point we get this position and
I've experimented with taking with the
Queen which is done well for me in blitz
but here I took with the knight and in
this game we played thousands of moves
of theory so to get to this position so
what it really revolves around largely
this position just based on the skeletal
outline of the pawn structure is control
over e5 so we're both going to be
fighting for that square because I don't
want white to get complete control
because if he controls he five then you
can blockade and then he can start
targeting my pawn in the future and so
already he's probably thinking about a
move like Bishop to f4 and obviously
he's the one that wants to trade the
dark squared Bishop because he's
fighting for control of a dark square so
I you know moved my queen to c7 this is
all still theory and so I've just
prevented his Bishop from going to f4
and so he has another way of trying to
sneak his Bishop around so yet again
he's going to try to trade bishops so I
played nine h5 so if it's Bishop goes
back to g3 I'll just take it with my
knife and I'll preserve my Bishop and
I'm you know I'm just fighting for
control over e5 okay so you went here so
you went here I think a little more
common is to check first and then go
here but has all been played before and
now I do his his moves so you could
pause at home but can you play like
Timothy over there in this position I
took his Knight so this is sort of the
active dynamic way that you want to play
this way because I do have a weakness
but I'm going to try to get some very
very active counter play so in the game
he took and this is all still theory and
so we reached some position you know and
again the game isn't the important part
I took all of this stuff all right so
I'm feeling pretty good about this
position already and after he played f4
trying to prevent me from playing a5
I played e5 anyway and the point is now
this guy this dormant Bishop was
you know pretty bad piece now he becomes
a superstar he goes to e4 and alright so
now things are already looking pretty
good for me and that's sort of the way I
got rid of my weakness I was playing
very actively I'm attacking so we got
this position and then for some reason
you know he traded into this end game
and this is just a winning endgame for
me so this really hasn't point of the
lecture and I don't really want to show
my own games
so we'll just speed through it I you
know I have to pass pawns
so I pushed him and I was able to win
this game so that's sort of what you
want to do when you have that sort of a
structure I got rid of my weakness and I
got some active dynamic play that's
that's the reason you would accept this
pawn structure and you sort of the thing
about the French - lets it's often very
positional very solid opening but it
does have the potential to be a very
dynamic weapon and you know even
aggressive players might find some
really sharp lines that they like to
play in the French so here's our third
pawn structure that we're going to look
at for the night and this pawn structure
could be achieved if you take and white
takes back with something let's say a
knight and the D for outpost can be a
very strong outpost for a knight that's
a great square for a night where it
can't be challenged by a pond so that's
what can happen here and again we have
more space over here as white
so we're thinking f4 f5 perhaps and if
you know black might be thinking I'll
get some counter play over here I'll
play pawn to b4 that's one of the breaks
that I have in my disposal sometimes
especially like in the classical
variation of the French white might be
castled over on this side in which case
both sides rushed to checkmate each
other so stuff like this can happen and
you know we all everybody tries to
checkmate everybody at the same time so
that also can lead to some very sharp
chess where it's opposite side castling
and there's there's lots of attacks
so let's go ahead and we'll look at my
loss so this we're only showing this one
because it's kind of funny how I chose
to lose this is my game against pre
dharshan Kanna pan from the Thanksgiving
open 2014 that was started off was it
was really good for me I mean it beat a
master in the first round and now I'm
playing in an IM who's still GM strength
he's actually just a couple weeks ago
officially feat I recognized his GM
title so he got all of his norms so now
he is as a GM and we'll get so st.
Louis's newest GM will look at at this
game where we got this structure okay so
here we are and so this is funny what I
chose to do here now my first instinct
is to Castle maybe Knight to c5 to
prevent Bishop d3 and maybe I jump in
here so those would be the obvious moves
that I should perhaps consider but at
the time I was watching a lot of TC EC
which is the chess engine competition
and I had seen a game between two
computers and the black computer had a
very interesting strategy that had never
been seen by humans and there's probably
a good reason in it it's probably not a
good strategy and unfortunately the
computer that did this with black it
lost but I said all right if it's good
enough for a computer it's good enough
for me and okay I sort of figured that
it was it was bad but I decided he won't
know this strategy so I'm going to do
something totally novel here oh yeah I
knew the computer lost that's but you
know it's playing use only and I am at
the time I'm like I'll do this and
you'll surprise them and it's good
enough for 3000 rated computer it should
be good enough for a human maybe and
I'll fool them and he won't know what to
do but the computer yeah so he was you
know 2500 or something yeah he's a good
player it's yeah he's a grandmaster now
so he's and he's always been sort of
grandmaster strength that's been he's
been he was an I am for a long time and
he's been way over 2500 so it's like
okay you're going to be a grandmaster at
some point soon here
and he so he finally did it so a big
congrats to uh to create our
shouldn't've if you're watching at home
alright so I did this I did some funny
queenside stuff with pieces and so all
of this actually resembled what happened
in the computer game so I got to do
everything I wanted but I guess the
moral of the story is don't play bad on
purpose against a grandmaster that's
that's the moral of the story here so
this was the thing so all of this
happened like in the computer game so I
was like so happy like yes all of this
you know very tactical nonsense and you
go here and then you get to pick up the
bishop and yeah I got the bishops and
then all right I'll get crushed later
and here unfortunately I made a big
blunder I should just probably take the
bishop with my queen I took with the
bishop because I thought before was
impossible but then he played before and
I'm like oh yeah I guess he can do that
I thought I had some sacrifice here I
don't even remember what it was like
maybe I was going to take with the
bishop or something but then I'm like oh
he just takes here and then he just
moves his king or something so I saw
something like this and I'm like yeah
this is it's not gonna work
so I think so I think I like it here he
would move one of these rooks I don't
know which one and even if this he can
like take it or something so I'm like
all right it didn't work so now I'm just
losing thing so the rest of the game is
pointless so I didn't sack because it
doesn't work and then I just lose I
decided to lose tactically so I traded
stuff tactically and then he even gave
up a pawn I was like darn and then here
he really crushed me so this is a great
move that he played I don't think I saw
it but there's nothing better I could do
anyway but oh all right now I'm just
crushed so here I missed a very good
opportunity to resign this would be a
nice nice time to do it but I decided to
check them I took this and then he gets
the last check so so now I resign
yes so I did something you a little
goofy but I thought it would be fun so
maybe I guess the lower rated opponent
it would have worked so they seem to do
well when I play mm and under
that's then the tactics all work for me
in this game he saw all my tactics and I
played bad on purpose so I lost but
there you go hopefully YouTube enjoyed
laughing at me a little bit so that
gives you hopefully a good indication as
to the the French pawn structure so you
hopefully know which side you should
play on hopefully it gives you a little
idea of where you should put your pieces
and these types of openings and yeah if
you want to see something else is there
a pawn structure that you guys really
want to see out there just let me know
in the comments below and perhaps next
time the pawn structure you guys pick
will be the one that I show here on
YouTube so thanks everybody for coming
out